Donald Trump is trying to go after the
Hispanic vote increasingly we know that
he has said he loves his
african-americans as he has pointed to
people in the crowd by the way the guy
he referred to as my african-american he
I guess is no longer a Republican so
that didn't go super well and Donald
Trump now trying to appeal to Hispanic
and Latino voters Trump did a campaign
rally yesterday in New Mexico the idea
was let's show up there and let's talk
about how low Hispanic unemployment is
and how great everything is and it went
about as poorly as you would expect
first of all bad poll after bad poll for
Donald Trump in some key swing states
for 2020
eight years of tax returns subpoenaed as
I already told you about new corruption
investigation into Trump's
Transportation Secretary who happens to
be Mitch McConnell's wife Elaine Chao so
Trump in the midst of all this shows up
in New Mexico and tries to appeal to
Hispanic voters sort of in the same way
that he tried to appeal to black voters
in 2016 which is blaming other people
for things and citing incorrect
statistics the clips are genuinely hard
to watch but also kind of fun listen to
Trump here as he talks about the
Hispanics as he refers to them by so
where the Hispanic American the
Hispanics were up with me in a poll 17%
and everyone said how is that
[Applause]
up by 70% I won't even tell you what the
final number was because they won't
believe it but you're gonna see what the
final number but you know why because
the hispanic-americans
they understand they don't want
criminals coming across the border they
don't want people taking their jobs they
want to have that security and they want
the wall they want the wall taking their
jobs it's truly hilarious that they
still use that stupid debunked bogus
talking point meant to completely
exculpate big corporations from the
immigration low wage status quo that
persists here in the United States and
more importantly the bigger lie there
Donald Trump claiming that Hispanics
want the border wall it's like no they
don't most of the country doesn't want
the border wall and if you're looking
specifically at Hispanic voters they we
I should say as part of that group we
don't want the border wall I mean
completely and totally untrue Trump also
heckled yesterday a bunch of times I was
only able in the time I had to prep this
morning I was only able to pull one clip
where you hear the heckling going on
Trump doing all the normal of attempts
to attempt to appeal to Hispanic voters
you'll hear him getting heckled after
the initial applause line here in the
background Trump just continues talking
over it and actually does successfully
yesterday marked the beginning of the
Hispanic Heritage Month who's Hispanic
here
Latinos fitrah
credible people but we have much to
celebrate unbelievable when you think
the unemployment for Hispanic Americans
is right now at the lowest level ever
recorded in the history of our country
Hispanic American poverty reached a
brand-new all-time low in history and
after years of stagnation that you know
very well wages for Hispanic Americans
are rising really fast up nearly eight
percent since my election those are
unheard of numbers and medium income
think of that median income for Hispanic
Americans surpassed fifty thousand
dollars for the first time ever so this
is the same type of pandering that we've
seen from Donald Trump before yes the
polls don't look good among Hispanics
for Donald Trump or in these swing
states but the only poll that matters in
the end is how people actually go and
vote in November of 2020 if they
actually choose to vote so despite all
this pandering despite all this rambling
and all of it that man that you just saw
talking about Hispanics and lying about
the wall he can still win in 2020 on
autopilot if we do not show up how a
Hispanic voter speaking as a Hispanic
voter myself can support Donald Trump at
this point I don't know and the rallies
make it even more confusing patronizing
marginalized and minority communities in
the most obviously transparent ways the
supporters are totally cringe worthy
it's an international embarrassment and
it actually in the end may all work to
get the guy reelected that's just the
the sole focus needs to be no matter how
cartoonish the clips I play for you no
matter how unbelievable and erratic and
and bogus are the claims that Donald
Trump makes he can get reelected in 2020
and
can do it even if his approval rating
drops 10 points mathematically that is
and so in the end all that matters is
that we actually go and vote in November
of 2020 and get as many people as
possible to go and do the same thing
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show and while you are there follow me
on instagram at david pakman we'll take
a quick break and back with oliver thorn
from philosophy tube right after this
hey I've got something really
interesting for you here a Jeanine Pirro
who is a former judge I'm shocked she
actually was a judge at one point and
it's an incredible indictment on the
American justice system she's now a Fox
News host she went on c-span and it did
not go well at all she has been one of
the persistent outrageous the opposite
of an ever Trumper and always trump ur
an unhinged defender of Donald Trump on
Fox News just persistently all the time
any crazy notion from Donald Trump she
will defend she went on a c-span program
called Washington journal people call in
to that show and she was straight-up
confronted by a caller this is a caller
from Texas who reamed her out so
severely in such a way that she was
visibly uncle' unsure what to do she
either could not respond or chose not to
respond
she looks visibly stunned by this
dressing down that a caller gave her
take a look at this our president and
our beautiful first lady they went down
to El Paso Texas and they posed with a
baby that the president's rhetoric
FoxNews renner your rhetoric had helped
to orphan and I think this this thing
about Trump is making America great
again Trump has made America hate again
and it's this hatred of races I hear it
all the time when I see talk to
Republicans and they say oh I went down
to Texas and there are all these
Mexicans down there and they're all
speaking Spanish well I Got News for you
those weren't Mexicans those were the
Americans that guy that went down to El
Paso to shoot a bunch of Mexicans he
shot a bunch of Americans and I'm
tired of this anti-immigrant anti people
with brown skin rhetoric that's coming
out of out of fox news coming out of
people like you and coming out of our
president it's demeaning it's beneath
the office it's beneath you you used to
be a judge you know better it's time
that that stopped and Thank You Carolyn
we'll get a response look you know what
I refuse to accept your recitation of
the facts you are dead wrong the problem
in this country the color of anyone and
don't you dare accuse me of any kind of
issue related to color I have 30 years
of prosecuting without fear or favor and
making sure that hate crimes were
vigorously prosecuted I for I fought for
a hate crimes law it's genuinely
shocking that she didn't interrupt and
the look on her face of growing
confusion and this almost inability to
jump in is really prices if you if
you're just listening you should
definitely watch the clip beautiful to
see now not everything the guy said was
a hundred percent true but he did pretty
accurately get into this idea of
stochastic terrorism that I've been
talking about for a long time and the
impact of what Jeanine Pirro and other
Fox Trump flunkies do and the effect
that it has on the real world she has
made commentaries on Fox News that have
suggested that Democrats entice
undocumented Hispanic immigrants to come
to the United States so that they can
vote for Democrats this is something
that had a prominent role in the El Paso
shooters manifesto the idea of I need to
go take out Hispanic people because
Democrats are in bed with them and
bringing them to the US to try to turn
elections in their favor I don't know
what's crazier that she was a judge
which is nuts I mean it is it is insane
that this is someone who was actually a
judge or that she continues to be a Fox
News host this not despite participating
in this sort of blind erratic reflexive
loyalty to the
and even kind of becoming an aggravating
factor in many of the problems that the
president is creating himself there are
actually lots of really crazy right-wing
judges we think of judges as these sort
of uh beyond partisanship arbiters of
the law in some way and you have to look
only at the fact that Jeanine Pirro was
a judge that crazy Texas congressman
Louie Gohmert was a judge if I recall
correctly and this gets to the bigger
problem of judges there are so many
right-wingers who talk about they want
textual conservative justices what they
are actually talking about are complete
and total partisan hacks who do the
opposite of simply be conservative if
conservative means merely applying the
letter of the law to the circumstances
if they do that if it helps Republicans
and big corporations or whoever they
want to help and if it doesn't they take
a completely different not conservative
but simply activist right-wing
perspective as judges for context here's
another caller
during Jeanine Pirro appearance who is a
complete and total right-wing lunatic
saying I'm not racist but we white
people legally obtained our guns drawing
a contrast I guess to non-white people
and then saying that Jeanine Pirro is a
genius and that Donald Trump would be
really well a would be really smart to
listen to her and also slam c-span
itself during the opening this is just
another caller
during Jeanine Pirro --za pearance hi
judge I know you thought you'd get a
fair shot here on Washington journal
c-span but as you see you get six to
seven Democrat callers to one Republican
that's that they're just as bad as CNN
with the fake knows about Donald Trump
they attacking just as much as anybody
but so 3ky you can sister because you
probably won't be invited back well I
mean let me jump in that's not true
we're taking calls from Democrats
Republicans and independents we welcome
here her for the hour and judge Jeanine
you are welcome back any time we'd love
to have you but caller go ahead thank
you so much I'm judging being
prosecutor I feel that the Democrats are
attacking only white people's guns and
I'm not being racist but what I'm saying
is we've legally obtained our guns we go
to buy our firearms we fill out
background checks and the thing that
upsets me the most and I do hope that
Donald Trump listens to you because I
know you are a very smart woman and we
need people like you talking to Donald
Trump but I feared that he doesn't see
what's going on you can find the rest of
that call online where they go into the
normal black on black crime talking
points and all of the stuff you would
expect really scary what's going on
why Jeanine Pirro is even on c-span is
beyond me that seems to be the real
problem selling her hack book but at
least one call are really backing her
off and she was visibly unclear about
how to respond let me know if you saw
this entire appearance it was wacky and
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show we will take a quick break and be
back right after this
so we had another weekend as often
happens every week and what that means
in practice is that our president has
again unleashed another furious tweet
storm riddled with spelling and grammar
errors and random capitalization of
words and the topic this time was
Supreme Court justice Brett Kavanaugh
there are new sexual assault allegations
against Brett Kavanaugh despite having
been told during the confirmation
hearings of wreck Cavanaugh that the FBI
looked into all of the allegations into
Brett Kavanaugh not surprising not
shocking more allegations of surfaced
including ones that the FBI did not look
into during his confirmation hearings
and the the particulars of the latest
allegation are that Cavanaugh exposed
his most intimate of areas use your
imagination to a female Yale classmate
and that others subsequently pushed the
hands of the classmate into Cavanaugh's
most intimate of areas nothing shocking
about this nothing surprising this seems
to just be who Brett Kavanaugh is it
became very very clear of course no
particular reason now to be concocting
this some of the normal Twitter
hangers-on suggests
that it's because we are now 14 months
from an alum an election that now some
bogus allegation against an already
confirmed Supreme Court justice who is
almost impossible to remove makes sense
for political reasons which I mean if
you're gonna concoct something concoct
something that actually has a shot at
doing some damage to the person involved
Donald Trump flying off the handle as a
result immediately suggesting that
Cavanaugh sufer listen to this one he
should sue for liable now why am i
pronouncing it liable because that's how
Trump spelled it Li a ble I guess
meaning of course Li BL libel a
published false statement damaging to a
person's reputation Trump concocting a
bizarre conspiratorial series of tweets
first tweeting Brett Kavanaugh should
start suing people for liable or the
Justice Department should come to his
rescue which by the way the Justice
Department coming to his rescue is an
extremely authoritarian suggestion Trump
going on the lies being told about him
are unbelievable false accusations
without recrimination when does it stop
they are trying to influence his
opinions can't let that happen
eventually Trump deleted it and reposted
it with the corrected spelling of a
libel and then kept going with more
quote can't let Brett Kavanaugh give
radical left Democrat liberal Plus
opinions each one of those words
capitalized why we don't know based on
threats of capital I impeaching him over
made-up stories sound familiar
false allegations and lies this is the
game they play fake and corrupt News is
working overtime
hashtag protect Cavanaugh I these are
the true these are the rantings of the
equivalent of someone again who's
yelling at you while they urinate on the
subway tracks on Canal Street of while
you wait for the 6:00 train I'll do one
more tweet not the entire list of tweets
because it's it's a quite frankly just
too much to keep up with Trump tweeting
I am fighting the fake corrupt news the
deep state the Democrats and the few
remaining Republicans in name only
rhinos who are on mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation with the help of some
truly great Republicans and others we
are winning big
150th federal judge this week now the
last thing Trump mentions there 150
federal judges Trump's right about this
I've talked about this before Supreme
Court selections get a lot of attention
federal judgeships much less so and
Donald Trump is actually winning really
big with those federal judgeship
selections it gets very little attention
it has a huge impact and it has a huge
impact for a very long time in most
cases never make it to the Supreme Court
a lot of the important precedent in this
country is ultimately decided by federal
judges many of which have now been
appointed by Donald Trump I think we
found that about 25% of current federal
and Superior Court I forget the
categorizations have been selected by
Trump in just two years and this has a
massive massive impact now as far as the
subject matter the idea of libel suits
against accusers of Kavanaugh consider
for a second that there have been what
15 16 1920 women who have accused Donald
Trump of anything ranging from verbal
sexual harassment all the way up to an
including rape Donald Trump has not
filed a single libel lawsuit I wonder
why that is
if anybody who is falsely accused of
sexual assault deserves to be have to
have a libel lawsuit filed against them
and it would be something in which one
could prevail why hasn't Donald Trump
filed a single libel lawsuit against all
of his accusers and of course there will
not be any libel lawsuits by Brett
Kavanaugh against these accusers either
and I think we all know why that is
going back once again to the idea from
Donald Trump's tweets that he's fighting
the fake corrupt media this is the last
thing I want to touch on Trump's not
fighting the fake corrupt media the fake
corrupt news media as Trump calls it or
I just call it corporate media they're
in on the game and what I mean by that
is that you have some in corporate media
that just will defend from endlessly or
almost endlessly like Fox News others
take a more critical editorial
perspective MSNBC others play the
enlightened watchdogs with bipartisan
panels like CNN but they're all
participating
the game they create and suck out all
the ratings that they can from the
distraction stories and narratives that
Donald Trump creates and then when the
time is up they just move on to the next
thing never really closing the book on
the impact of each of these narratives
and Trump is simply wrong because they
are actually working with him the fight
is the public spin on it but the reality
is that corporate media have been in
with Trump including the billions and
free publicity that they gave him from
the time he started his campaign that is
backwards Trump has that backwards and
again Trump is completely erratic and
unhinged every single weekend on Twitter
so we're all very very familiar with
Donald Trump's lack of diplomatic skill
but today we have a story that takes
this to a new level that actually seems
almost satirical but in a way it's a
refreshing sort of reality that tells us
something arguably positive about Donald
Trump and since these things are so few
and far between I do want to pay some
special attention to it you'll remember
that not long ago the g7 was held in
Biarritz France and we covered all of
the comings and goings and one of the
things that we're now learning about are
the details of a meeting that Donald
Trump was going to have with the
Egyptian president Abdel Fattah al-sisi
and according to The Wall Street Journal
/ multiple people in the room Donald
Trump arrived looking around for el Sisi
and called out where's my favorite
dictator which resulted in what was
described as stunned silence in the room
apparently a joke one set of reactions
was it's not really a joke Donald Trump
loves dictators or at least he loves
authoritarians this includes his praise
of Kim jong-un her Diwan she Putin Saudi
Prince Mohammed bin Salman
Duterte etc he's just saying this guy is
my favorite dictator I love dictators
and this guy's my favorite dictator the
argument over whether it is a joke
though I think is the wrong one this is
an extreme example of a clueless person
not knowing how politics is done yeah
it's more of the same total lack of
decorum and diplomacy that Donald Trump
brings to everything that he does
because he's just ignorant to all of it
but there is a way in which I'm actually
relieved to hear Donald Trump call one
of these authoritarians a dictator even
if it's not literally the truth and I'll
explain why in a second now on the on
the facts is LCCC a dictator he is often
called a dictator he's certainly an
authoritarian he gives the military
unchecked power he overthrew a
democratically elected president in 2013
in a coup to take power
he's killed hundreds of protesters he's
imprisoned tens of thousands of
dissidents of different kinds there are
allegations of torture of disappearing
journalists and activists and
allegations of abduction I mean really
just horrible terrible terrible stuff
and he is a violent authoritarian if not
a dictator now the reason I find this
refreshing in some way from Donald Trump
is trumps already thrown decorum out the
window he's thrown diplomacy out the
window who cares about that this is just
one more example and what is one more
instance of that at this point in time I
am glad that Donald Trump called
something at least by what it might be
if again if not literally a dictator a
dictatorial authoritarian el Sisi when
it comes to these authoritarian
strongmen I would prefer that Donald
Trump call them what they are or at
least something closer to what they are
instead of merely praising them and
placating them and working to please
them and complimenting them he has
already done it with LCCC back in 2017
he talked about LCCC's doing a great job
and made all sorts of just completely
outrageous statements that ignore the
endless I mean just endless human rights
abuses that we've seen there so is it
embarrassing for Donald Trump to walk
into a room and say where's my favorite
dictator of course it's embarrassing is
it hilariously undec or
that's a word
of course it is but evidence that Trump
recognizes dictators for what they are
authoritarian for what they are is
slightly positive is this actual praise
of Donald Trump big picture of course
it's not but it arguably in a way it
actually makes his praise of
authoritarian dictatorial types even
worse it would be one thing if Trump
doesn't recognize that that's what they
are and just kind of likes the fact that
he sees them as strong figures Putin
duterte all of them it's in a sense
worse if he recognizes that they are
dictatorial authoritarians and still
praises them but he's at least calling
things closer to what they are so big
picture it's not like I like Trump now
but I respect the fact that he actually
entered the room and yelled this out
even if it is completely outrageous
diplomatically because it confirms that
Trump recognizes these people for what
they are the fact that he likes them
signals a problem with his moral compass
and moral the moral compass of Trump is
what we'll talk about next
but in a sense he is not as disconnected
from reality as maybe we thought at the
end of last week if I'm missing this if
my take on this miss is something else
let me know but I actually found it
refreshing to hear Donald Trump refer to
el Sisi at least by something closer to
what he is rather than just a great
leader the way Donald Trump refers to
most of these a dictatorial dictatorial
authoritarians let me know what you
think so we need to have just like a
very real and honest conversation today
about the reality that Donald Trump just
always gets his ass kicked
internationally by everyone and I don't
like it and I want to know whether you
see it my way and whether this is
something you're concerned about and I'm
not talking about any kind of delusional
my framework for this is not some hyper
nationalists the US needs to always come
out quote winning at the expense of
every other country I want us working
together with the international
community I want to solve serious
problems in productive ways as as an
alliance of countries but what I mean is
why is it that Donald Trump is always
the
loser in negotiations often negotiations
he shouldn't be participating in always
the laughingstock always the guy that
the adults in the room often aren't even
inviting into the room anymore because
his presence is so pointless and
counterproductive that's what I want to
talk about today it is embarrassing that
the president can't stop getting his ass
kicked
day in and day out it's it's boneheaded
stupidity and I'm going to give you some
examples there's lots of good ones by
the way
in a recent DailyKos piece which I
recommend you check out by Lawrence
Lewis which was posted to our subreddit
Donald Trump as an example is now
considering jumping into a fifteen
billion dollar French bailout of Iran if
Iran is willing to come back into the
Iran nuclear deal a be back in
compliance with the Iran nuclear deal
there are people so out of touch with
reality that they see this as Donald
Trump being the big strong negotiator
but this is maybe the most ignorant ly
myopic view of international relations
and specifically of the Iran deal than I
can imagine remember Donald Trump bailed
out of the Iran nuclear deal
even though Iran had been in compliance
ever since the deal was signed it was an
international embarrassment for the
United States to just not stick to our
agreements without anyone else having
violated them why would we not stick to
our side of the deal the other countries
including France had to try at the g7 to
salvage what was potentially left and
one of the things that they said was
okay if the US is out we get that it's
logical that you might try to start
researching nuclear technology and
developing it and it could potentially
be used for weapons what can we do to
keep you in compliance and one of the
things they came up with was a $15
French a 15 billion dollar French
bailout which now Donald Trump is
considering participating in because he
wants Iran to be compliant with the
nuclear deal this is only a conversation
this is only on the table because Trump
bailed on the nuke deal to begin with
for no reason whatsoever just getting
his ass
getting it kicked internationally
another obvious example is North Korea
we're going to talk more about North
Korea later on in today's program Trump
is so desperate to be liked and so
overconfident in his negotiating skills
that he doesn't even realize that
there's this long history of North
Korean leaders manipulating the United
States or trying to manipulate the
United States and Trump goes and meets
with Kim jong-un no preconditions pranic
plenty of pompous bluster comes out
thinking that he negotiated some
incredible deal that no one else has
been able to do even though it was the
same promises that the Kim family has
been making for decades claims victory
and then of course nothing happens and
meanwhile North Korea nuclear and
weapons development just keeps going on
ballistics missiles missile tests Trump
getting his ass kicked internationally
again one more example I think you're
getting the sort of gist of it the
Chinese trade war Trump thinks I'll
throw some tariffs at China they'll
buckle down the US will win however he
defines that never mind that he doesn't
even understand how tariffs work he
doesn't understand how the us-china
relationship works and China instead
says okay you're putting tariffs on us
we'll put tariffs on you we'll get our
aluminum and our steel elsewhere we'll
make a deal with Russia for energy
development and exploration we'll get
our soy elsewhere and Trump gets his ass
kicked again
crushing farmers crushing related
industries and the world is just
wondering what is this guy doing why is
he doing this could we maybe not have a
president getting his ass kicked weekly
and I've been very careful when I make a
comparison between Trump and George W
Bush I don't want to do it in any way
that suggests George W Bush was anything
other than a neoconservative maniac with
terrible policies Bush didn't get his
ass kicked in this way internationally
week in and week out Bush made terrible
policy decisions I disagreed with his
moral framework based on born-again
Christianity or whatever it was that he
most recently ascribed to he was a war
monger economically I didn't agree with
the guy but he wasn't getting his ass
kicked in the bone had
way that Donald Trump is weakened and
week-out our historical allies are
looking around wondering what's wrong
with this guy it's not just that they
disagree with the decisions or the
underlying policy to the extent Trump
has an underlying political philosophy
they just can't understand why he keeps
doing the most boneheaded things to his
own disadvantage and it's reflecting
extremely poorly on the United States
the world you know the the Trump may
have high approval among red-state
Republicans 55-plus I'm sure among that
group his approval rating is off the
chart but the world is wondering how
could Americans be so dumb and this is
the way they're thinking about us now
how could they be so dumb as to have
voted this guy in in the first place we
need to change that in November of next
year and I hope that we will so Donald
Trump's taxes are back in the news and
have actually been subpoenaed by the
Manhattan district attorney state
prosecutors in Manhattan have subpoenaed
Donald Trump's accounting firm demanding
eight years of both Trump's personal and
business tax returns now the first
question we might ask is district
attorney if a district attorney is
issuing a subpoena for Donald Trump's
tax returns is this related to some kind
of investigation and the answer is that
yes it turns out that at the end of
August a criminal investigation was
opened up into those hush money payments
made by Donald Trump to mistresses and I
know many of us are completely fatigued
and sick of this hush money thing by now
and I'll sort of address that in a
second these are the payments that were
made the payments were made in a in a
literal sense by trumps now in prison
personal attorney Michael Cohen but of
course they were made in service to
Donald Trump and Donald Trump as far as
we know reimburse those payments to
Michael Cohen so that's the answer to
question one it's part of that
investment investing question two is
what's the full scope of this Manhattan
district attorney probe is it related
only to the 2016 hush money payments or
is there some broader campaign finance
or other investigation that this is part
of we don't know the answer to that we
know that one legal question
about the hush money particularly the
payment made to stormy Daniels is did
Donald Trump's business call that a
legal expense in their accounting which
would be number one hilarious and number
two potentially illegal and a felony if
it was done to conceal some other crime
like tax evasion or bank fraud or in the
service of some additional crime so
we'll figure that out maybe someday but
let's get more to what matters here and
what doesn't matter I understand we are
mostly sick of this entire hush money
payment thing the hush money payments
themselves as a way to punish Donald
Trump or make him suffer consequences
for the things that he did I believe
that that ship has sailed we can as a
practical matter vote Donald Trump out
way faster than the hush money payment
investigation could even potentially
remove him from office it's just not
going to happen we shouldn't even be
thinking about that then we get to the
content of the tax returns themselves
that's actually what we're interested in
now that being said this is a district
attorney subpoena for an investigation
if they get the tax returns meaning if
the grand jury gets those tax returns
they would not even go public unless
they're leaked of course unless they end
up becoming evidence at a trial that is
also extremely unlikely to happen so I
don't really see this as something to be
optimistic about in terms of the
material getting to us for our review
but it's yet another thing that could
trigger Donald Trump first of all
secondly every time that we do hear
anything related to the content of
Donald Trump's taxes it's been something
that makes him look terrible so there is
still the potential here that if any of
this is released in any way leaked or
otherwise it's going to contain
extremely damaging information about
Donald Trump remember that when the
summaries of Donald Trump's tax returns
got out we learned that he lost just
like insane amounts of money and they
put out his attorney or someone put out
a statement saying oh this is all
calculated
you know he's gaming the system and this
is all because he's such a great
businessman people who were not working
for Trump who know about tax law and
looked at it and said no no this is just
the guys really losing a lot a lot of
money or he lost a lot of money in that
time it would not be for the tax
benefits we also learned from other tax
disclosures of Trump that we got a while
ago that Donald Trump's dad had financed
a lot of Donald Trump's failures we call
that Rich Dad bails me out just like the
height of privilege for someone claiming
to be a self-made man so this could be
interesting if something like that comes
out it could be interesting in that even
just fighting it could become a big
story and expensive for Donald Trump
which would be just delightful but as
far as getting rid of Trump as far as
exposing criminality the strategy
remains the same one that it's been for
more than a year vote Trump out in
November of 2020 he'll be gone when a
new president is inaugurated in January
of 2021 and it will be far far more
efficient than any of these ideas
related to tax returns or the 25th
amendment or impeachment I know the fans
of each of those individually will say
no those are great ideas David and they
may well be but they're not going to get
Trump out any faster than just voting
him out in November if you disagree with
me let me know so we have some pretty
big geopolitics to talk about today over
the weekend some Saudi oil facilities
were attacked and the Trump
administration is increasingly looking
at Iran as the culprit and before we get
into sort of like the specific analysis
anytime in the Trump era that we're
doing an analysis of geopolitics there's
sort of like the normal analysis one
would do based on the last 200 years of
American history and then you have to
modify that analysis to account for the
fact that Donald Trump is President of
the United States an analogy that came
to me over the weekend is sort of like
if you have an airline pilot that flies
a particular airplane right an Airbus
330 and you say what is the take-off
speed of the Airbus 330 and you have
you're like in a vacuum answer which
might be a hundred and fifty knots but
then much like you have to account for
Donald Trump being president in
geopolitics you then have to account for
whether the runway is dry or wet and
what is the elevation of the airport and
other things and you might end up with
an answer where well in this particular
case the take-off speed for an Airbus
330 is 160 knots when accounting for
these other fact
and similarly with Donald Trump thrown
into geopolitics we have to account for
Donald Trump in making our evaluation so
a few different things to go over it's
the event that took place the hypocrisy
from Donald Trump and also the growing
subservience by Donald Trump to the
Saudis which is something that we should
all be extremely worried about in
particular because of the connections we
already know Trump and Jared Kushner and
others around him have to the Saudis so
first of all why the focus on Iran so
far what we know is that a number of
Saudi oil facilities were attacked over
the weekend we have satellite images
that show 17 points of impact coming
from the north or the northwest which
could be Iran it could be Iraq now in
the immediate and the Iranian backed
Houthi militias are hootie militias I'm
never sure how to pronounce that from
Yemen claimed responsibility and there
are reasons to be skeptical about this
the direction of the attacks is at least
a potential reason to be skeptical the
use of cruise missiles and drones seem
to exceed the known capabilities of the
Houthis and Donald Trump as usual is
reacting to everything in the worst
possible way erratic indirect and sort
of showing his cards that he is indeed
subservient to the Saudis hypocritical
subservience is maybe how I would sum it
up so first of all Donald Trump tweeting
Saudi Arabia oil supply was attacked
there is reason to believe that we know
the culprit are locked and loaded
depending on verification but are
waiting to hear from the kingdom as to
who they believe was the cause of this
attack and under what terms we would
proceed look at all of the extremely
disturbing elements just to this one
tweet hinting at Iran but not saying it
we have reason to believe we know who
did it why not just come out and say it
locked and loaded it's a threat of
violence but again it's predicated on
Donald Trump having reason to believe
that he knows who it is but saying that
one
the Saudis tell him who they believe did
it he's locked and loaded and ready to
go under whatever terms the Saudis say
are the ones that Donald Trump should
operate under this is a level of
subservience to the Saudis and then we
get to the hypocrisy because Donald
Trump in 2014
tweeted quote Saudi Arabia should fight
their own Wars which they won't or pay
us an absolute fortune to protect them
and their great wealth trillion dollars
of course Donald Trump was not president
at the time Barack Obama was president
at the time
so was that just BS and political
bluster probably the other possibility
is Donald Trump actually has made some
kind of deal with the Saudis for the
u.s. to be their protector and in a way
that deal has sort of been made in plain
sight for decades through American
foreign policy Donald Trump may well see
and it actually wouldn't be that crazy
he may see the endless and infinitely
growing arms deals with Saudi Arabia as
that sort of payment to the United
States for the protection of the Saudis
you may recall that when Barack Obama
sort of semi bowed to the Saudis when
they were greeting each other the right
went crazy
even though george w bush was kissing
the Saudis on the cheek and they seemed
fine with it at the time now Donald
Trump is saying when the Saudis tell me
who they think did it and when the
Saudis tell me what the appropriate
response would be we're gonna go out and
do it really strong leader right
projecting strength and independence and
focusing on what's best for the oh wait
no he's really not some of the bigger
political questions here does Donald
Trump want a war with someone to help
the arms industry is that sort of what
is at the core of what's going on here
does Donald Trump want a war with
someone so that he can finally be the
tough guy that he of course is not but
desperately wants to be does Donald
Trump want a war with someone because he
believes it will help his reelection
after all that would not be incorrect in
a sense I'm trying to think of when the
United States voted out an incumbent
president in the middle of a war or
significant military
engagement and I'm having trouble
thinking of that maybe there are
examples and/or because this is all
obviously not just one thing it could be
a combination dis Donald Trump want a
war because it will be a distraction
from one of his many current or upcoming
scandals a combination is usually sort
of the right answer with this president
I got a lot of emails from the audience
over the last year saying David at some
point Trump is going to war the question
is who will it be against and under what
pretenses but the guy is going to find a
war one way or another either john
bolton is going to help him or if john
bolton is the impediment bolton will go
which he since has and trump will find a
war on his own maybe not more cynical
than reality actually suggests here and
of course immediately the economic
impact is significant relatively minor
in the context of the broader insanity
but oil price is spiking about one sixth
from sixty to seventy one dollars we
don't even get that much of our oil from
Saudi Arabia the notion that we are
dependent on the Saudis for the oil
itself is wrong I mean they have a big
market share but from my recollection we
get around eleven percent of our total
oil consumption from foreign countries
and of that eleven percent
I think it's nine percent only is from
Saudi Arabia so the actual numbers don't
bear it out but of course a massive
player in OPEC and in controlling the
oil market so an economic impact right
away I don't know where this will go
we'll keep following it I want to hear
from you about it but this is of course
going to be a very very crazy year
leading up to the November 20 2011